Oh, you guys.
I'm so fucked right now.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'll tell you what.
I am going through some fumes right now.
Because if anybody fucked up right now, it's me.
Because I am fucking crazy.
Let me get some lo-fi.
Lo-fi copy, right?
Free.
First, let's get some lo-fi in there before we start anything.
Lo-fi!
No copyright!
Okay, but is this the one with...
Alright, let's see.
No, I don't trust that playlist.
There's like... Okay, I write down like lo-fi, no copyright.
And then like sometimes they give me lo-fi playlists that does have copyright.
Which is very fucked because it's like false advertising.
Okay, so I'm running with no coffee right now or tea or anything.
No caffeine at all.
Because I have no caffeine.
I have no caffeine at all in my old apartment.
Which is not good.
It is not good at all.
So, we're sort of gonna be roughing it right now.
We're gonna be doing our fucking best.
We're gonna fucking try and survive.
So, how can you live like that?
Because all my tea is in my new apartment and not at my old apartment.
So, I have no tea right now.
And then I thought I had... I mean, I have coffee.
But it's like an open can of coffee that I opened three weeks ago.
So, I don't know.
Don't really want to...
I don't really want to drink coffee that was open three weeks ago.
It's canned coffee, by the way.
It's not like hot coffee that's been left out for three weeks.
But it's canned coffee that's been out for three weeks in the fridge.
It's been in the fridge for three weeks right now.
So, like, I do not want to drink that.
No, because thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, let me tell you how I fucked up my schedule.
So, I had Anime Revolution yesterday.
And I had Anime Revolution today.
And I have Anime Flan tomorrow.
I knew I might have fucked up.
Past Doki was like, future Doki can do this.
What's the worst thing that could happen?
Having two conventions back to back.
Well, current Doki realized that there's a lot of things that could happen.
So, basically...
Basically, I had a very late night concert with Mint.
And then, from there, I had the meet and greets.
Yeah?
So, by that time, I finished around 11ish PM.
11 PM to...
11 PM, almost close to 12 PM.
I don't really remember exactly the time of everything.
And then...
And then, after that, I had stayed up to finish some work stuff.
And then, after that, I had to take a public transport all the way back to my new apartment.
Because I didn't want to pay an Uber.
I...
I did not.
I already...
Like I said, I already used up a lot of money.
Moving and, like, Ubering and food.
So, like, I haven't bought groceries yet at my new apartment or anything.
So, I've been...
Money...
I gotta cut corners when I can.
I really...
I really do.
Like, I know, like, I make more money than I did before.
But, like, I still...
It still hurt, you know?
It still...
It still hurt.
So...
So, basically...
I got home at my new apartment.
Which has nothing, by the way.
You might think there's an echo here right now.
But, like, at my new place, it's, like...
It's, like, echoing a lot.
So, like, this is also echoing a lot as well.
So...
So, there's, like...
By the way, I have zero furniture.
Zero furniture.
Other than my work desk.
My work desk.
And, like, one chair.
Wait, no.
Two chairs.
Including my work chair.
That's literally...
And my bed.
I don't have a couch.
I don't think I want...
Guys.
Okay.
I'll explain how this is gonna work later.
But I need to tell my day.
Okay?
I need to let out some steam about my...
I'm also, like, leaning back.
Okay.
There you go.
If you feel like I'm, like, really far...
Because I was leaning back on...
Now I'm being dokey.
So...
So, basically...
I got home at around, like, 1ish AM.
And I went to bed.
I went to sleep instantly.
Because...
I...
Today...
My day started at 7 in the morning.
And, like, it was so funny.
Because my panel is at 10 in the morning.
And then the dragoons there at Anime Revolution was like, yeah, it's so early.
I never expected your panel to be that early.
And I was like, it was not a choice.
Hahaha.
I was just like...
I was like, I would never pick 10 AM for anything.
Hahaha!
It was not a choice.
It was!
Hahaha!
Haha!
Yeah!
Hahaha!
Anyway...
Anyway.
As I was saying...
I was like...
I woke up...
at...
7 in the morning.
I woke up at...
7... 7 in the morning and I was so fucking... I was so fucking tired and thing is, even though I woke up at 7 in the morning, I didn't leave the... I didn't leave the apartment until like much...
Well, I had tech rehearsals at 8 a.m.
and I straight up was like, I will be late.
I woke up, texted, texted the... because even though I woke up at 7 a.m., if I left around...
If I got dressed and left around like instantly, I would have made it for the tech rehearsal.
But I didn't do that.
I... I did not do that.
I woke up, looked at the server with Anime Revolution and literally wrote, I'm going to be late.
Because I know myself.
I know myself and I knew I was not gonna get there in time.
I was like, I can't.
I was like, literally, I was like...
I can't.
I was so fucking out of it.
So, I got back to my old apartment at like 8 in the morning.
8 in the morning.
No, 8.30.
I got back at my old apartment at like...
8... 8... 8.30...
8.30...
It's 3 a.m.
and basically what happened was that I did my tech rehearsal and then went to get breakfast and I got back just in time for the panel and after the panel, I went straight to... after the panel, I fucking went straight to... I went straight into the...
straight into the... God, sorry, my brain is like short-circuiting right now.
I went straight into the meet-and-greet and after the meet-and-greet, I found out, for those who weren't at my Twitch stream earlier, I literally found out that I was the captain of the Apex Twitch Rivals thing.
Because I was getting messages from four different people that I was late for the team draft and everybody was waiting for me.
My meet-and-greet ended.
I was late at 1.05 and then I... people were spamming me messages at like 1 because I was late and they're like, where's Toki?
And I was like, I didn't know I was captain.
I know I talked about it in the Twitch Rivals stream, but like... but like, I didn't know.
I signed up for it, like, so late.
I signed up for the Twitch Rivals so late.
And then Temple... because Temple was messaging me and being like, you're late for it.
You're... you're late for your draft thing.
And I was like, what?
And like, don't you have the draft channel access?
And I was like, I don't look at the server.
I only look at the server when like, I'm about to stream.
Like, I was like... I was like, what do you mean?
No one messaged me that I was captain.
I only found out because... apparently, because I had the perms.
To see the channel that I was captain, that should have... I should have automatically, no, but I'm like, I don't look at that.
I don't... I don't look at the fucking channels.
I just show up when it's time to show up.
I...
So, yeah, so I had zero rest and that's why... that's why I needed that 30 minute break.
I needed that 30... I needed... how do I keep getting invites?
And I was like, I'm going to invite it back because they love me.
I'm a riot.
I show up when it's time for me to show up.
I am so fucking hilarious.
That's why they always invite me.
But anyway, that is why I am very exhausted right now.
Because I honestly...
I honestly thought I had coffee today, not that I had coffee today, but I honestly thought that I had coffee in my fridge, because I usually always have coffee in my fridge, but I forgot that I'm moving.
By the way, tomorrow I have the animathon panel, the animathon panel in Minigree, and then straight to moving.
Oh yeah, and then straight to Gumi's birthday, and then moving.
Because Gumi was spam messaging me about it, and I felt really bad because I was so busy, I didn't see her messages.
She wanted to personally invite me to her birthday stream.
So I'll be in Gumi's birthday stream for a couple of... one or two games for Crab Game.
And then after that, I'll be packing again.
I'm going to be packing.
It doesn't mean I'm moving tomorrow, but I have to start packing and everything tomorrow for my final move.
Because I already arranged an appointment, so I need to pack for my final fucking move.
So everything will be at my new apartment, and I don't have to do the goddamn commute anymore.
I can be free and never go outside again.
That is my goal.
I need to have my new apartment furnished, and then never touch the outside ever again.
Except to walk dad.
That's...
That's all I need.
I just... I see the outside.
By the way, my PC room...
This, the current PC room at the moment, I can see the outside.
I purposely chose my new PC room where there is no windows.
Because I do not need any more windows.
It sounds so funny.
The room that's going to be my PC room will have zero windows.
I don't need natural light.
I don't...
I will see the outside when I have to walk dad.
There's a windows...
There's windows outside the PC room.
But the PC room has zero windows.
What if you need fresh air?
That's what Amazon Prime is for.
I can order the fresh air from the fucking mountain Alps.
You're making a depression chamber.
That is the sacrifice I'm willing to make.
I am tired of living in the fucking greenhouse chat.
Like, I don't know if you know this.
But like, I... I... I hate my room that is like...
Okay, I just realized.
This is pissing me off a little bit.
But give me a sec.
I need to like...
This is actually brilliant.
I'm going to disappear for a second guys.
I realized there's something going on.
That's like really annoying me at the moment.
I was off-centered and I need to be...
I can't.
I'm not... I don't have ADHD.
I just... I just can't be...
I can't.
I was like, I'm off-centered.
I...
I have to be centered again.
I can't.
I can't deal with that.
Okay, sorry.
I don't have OCD either.
I don't have...
I'm just really tired.
I mean, we invented curtains for a reason.
Also, hope this helps the moving funds.
Thank you for the akasupa, Lord Krosus.
Thank you, thank you.
I really, really do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
And now that I've acknowledged that.
I was off-centered.
You're going to look back the VOD.
And it's going to piss you off when you see the VOD.
And you see I'm off-centered.
No, I'm not.
Now I'm not off-centered.
Look, I'm perfectly centered now.
Chat, look.
I'm perfectly centered.
Anyway.
There are light bulbs that replicates light of the sun for mental health reasons.
It's all right.
There's no way my mental health...
I'm okay, guys.
I just want you guys to know I'm...
That was a joke, guys.
That was...
I think she has...
That was just a very...
A very dark joke.
I'm just very...
I'm just tired.
Don't do this to us.
I'm just...
Okay.
The reason why I purposely picked a room with no windows is that I'm very tired of living in a fucking green...
I'm very tired of having a greenhouse as my PC workroom.
Because, like, it's...
Oh, my God.
It's always so fucking hot.
It's so hot.
It's pissing me off.
Because, like, the sun shines into the windows and then, like...
And it, like, heats everything up.
And, like, no amount of air conditioning can fix this.
It just can't fix it.
Because I'm literally...
I have fucking two, four, five windows.
I have five fucking giant ass...
Those, like, windows that almost touch the floor.
And I'm in the sun.
It's just...
Oh, my God.
Look at me.
I'm just, like, fucking shining onto my body and giving me their UV radioactive rays.
And...
No!
It doesn't work!
The curtains barely fucking hide it!
It's still hot!
It still comes through!
It doesn't fucking do anything!
It...
It doesn't work.
The curtains aren't strong enough to block the sun!
We gotta destroy the sun.
Like...
Okay.
Let's see.
Come on.
Anyway, so like, I've given up and I'm just, um, okay, you need, that's what my bedroom's for, right?
That's what, if I, okay, guys, you're like, that's what the, then it's counterintuitive!
If I block the sun with curtains!
Guys, guys, I don't know if you guys know this, but like, um, that's very counterintuitive.
If you want me to get, like, curtains that block the sun, what if I just not have windows?
I would, I would never, if I actually get those curtains, I would never, like, I would never, like, unfurl, like, I would never make, like, what's it called, pull the curtains back, like, I would never open the curtains if I actually got those.
So I could have the option.
Guys, you know damn well I will not pick the option.
I will not.
I, you know, damn well I will not use the option.
Yeah, but thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
As a Texan with windows, I hear your pain.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Guys, guys, the earth is slowly...
We're, we're slowly being heated up right now.
You know, people are willing to pay for more for that kind of sunlight, right?
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, and a lot of those people are from Scandinavia.
Uh...
The thing is, the thing is...
I live, I live in Canada and like, I live in the west coast of Canada.
Because you're in the west coast of Canada, there's too much sun sometimes.
There's way too much sun.
Um...
Anyway, how is this gonna work?
So...
I have no furniture.
And I need help for you guys.
To help me figure out what to buy.
I also want people to help me.
Uh...
I need some people to help.
I need you guys to help me figure out, like...
Uh...
Stuff for my shrine!
Uh, so...
I'm trying to construct my shrine at the moment.
And also, like, trying to figure out, like, what...
I'm not gonna buy from Ikea.
Guys, Ikea is very convenient.
But their furniture is fucking...
Okay, their furniture is... You do... Okay.
I never buy desks for...
From Ikea.
Because... Oh, the Doki Shrine!
Oh my god, let me show you guys the Doki Shrine.
I'm so excited to show you guys this.
Alright, let me show you guys the Doki Shrine.
So, I'm making a shrine right now.
Of all the stuff that everybody has given me.
Um...
And I wanna have, like, little stands and stuff.
Uh, no, I didn't update it.
So, I wanna have, like, little stands and stuff.
So I can put more stuff...
Um...
In places.
So I can use...
Use the...
So, like, people have given me some of these.
Some of these are, like, things I bought and stuff.
So, I really wanna have...
Uh...
Um...
I really wanna have, like...
Like, ideas on how...
On, like...
Equipment on...
Uh...
What to...
What to buy...
To make a really good Doki Shrine.
And, like, display.
I... Okay!
I don't know if you guys know...
Like...
Like, I don't know if you guys know...
Any products.
Cause I want, like, these little things.
So I was, like, thinking about getting a little...
I don't know if glass or plastic would be better.
But, like, I wanna have, like...
Um...
Like, not a frame.
Not like a...
Like an art...
Like a...
Art frame.
But, like...
Cause I was thinking I should get a cork board.
Or, like...
Um...
A thing where I can, like...
Press a lot of, like, letters and stuff.
Fan mail and everything.
And then, like...
Press it onto, like, the board.
And then have, like, a plastic thing on top of it.
Or, like, acrylic.
Or glass on top of it.
And then, like...
Hang it.
With all the...
With all the, like, fan letters and everything.
Um...
And...
I need, like...
I wanna figure out, like...
What...
Like, what that is.
Cause I don't wanna...
I don't wanna use cork...
The reason why I don't wanna use cork board...
Is because I don't wanna...
I don't wanna...
I don't wanna get, like...
I don't wanna damage the letters.
I don't wanna damage the paper.
Or anything.
That's the thing.
I don't wanna damage it with, like...
Pins and...
Um...
Uh...
And stuff.
I wanna know if there's, like...
A thing where, like...
Um...
A thing where I could just, like...
Press these fan letters up against it.
And I don't wanna laminate them.
Because I don't wanna...
No, I wanna...
I wanna hang it.
I don't wanna, like...
I wanna hang it, too.
I don't wanna be able to...
I don't wanna, like...
Damage the paper and everything.
So, like...
I'm trying to, like...
I wanna know if there's, like...
If there's, like...
Products that you can do that.
Cause it feels like...
Something that should exist.
But I want it to be, like...
Hanged.
Cause I wanna see it.
I don't wanna be in the scrapbook or anything.
Cause, like...
I wanna be able to see it.
Like...
On the wall.
Or something.
Um...
But...
Ashram, thank you for the 10 gifted ships.
Thank you.
So, I really would love some ideas.
On, like...
Like, stuff that can help improve my shrine.
I, like...
Saved some links and stuff.
Wait, let me see if I can...
Pull it up.
I, like...
Saved some...
Links.
I have, like...
A tab that wrote...
Furniture.
Like, I saw stuff like this.
And I thought it was super cute.
Okay.
I don't know if you can see the picture right now.
Um...
Basically, I saw stuff like this.
Which I thought was super cute.
For, like...
This thing.
Like, small...
Like, plushies.
Or stuff.
No, I don't wanna laminate it.
Cause I don't wanna, like...
Damage it.
Not damage it.
But I don't wanna make it permanent.
You know?
Like, I don't wanna have it, like...
A permanent thing.
But, like...
I also don't wanna...
Do magnets.
Because, like...
I don't wanna, like...
I'd rather it, like...
Be pressed up.
So that...
It doesn't need to be, like...
What's the word?
Um...
I don't need to have, like...
Multiple magnets.
Just on the board.
Oh, and then I saw these, too.
These were really cute, as well.
I saw these, like...
Um...
These being used as, like...
Displays and stuff.
Which...
Um...
Wait, let me...
Let me save this picture.
I thought these were really cute.
To be used to display, like...
Acrylic stands.
Or charms.
I was thinking about, like...
Hanging them.
Or something.
Hanging the acrylic charms.
Um...
I don't know.
Save the image.
Is it a web?
Oh, my God.
It's a fucking web.
God damn it.
I hate it when it's...
I hate it when it's a web and...
And be, like...
Who the fuck uses that?
Like...
Stuff like...
Like this.
I thought this was really cute.
I thought this was also...
Really cute, too.
Um...
I'm, like...
Thinking if I should get, like...
Actual...
I don't want to get couches.
Because, like...
A couch is such a...
The thing is...
I'm not going to have a TV.
So...
Um...
I'm not going to have a TV.
So, like...
I...
Honestly, like...
Oh, what is a shadow box?
I don't know what a shadow box is.
Shadow box.
What is a shadow box?
No.
Because then it's a box.
I want it to be, like...
Flat.
You know?
Like, I want it to be, like...
Flat.
Like a cork board.
But, like...
I don't want to damage it.
I'm not going to have a TV.
Who...
Okay.
Who said no TV?
Who the...
Who the fuck uses...
How are you going to watch sports?
I don't want to have a couch.
Because I'm just, like...
When am I going to...
Why...
When will I ever sit in the living room?
Like...
When...
When the fuck would I ever sit in the living room?
Like...
It's just...
It's so stupid.
I don't...
I don't even...
I don't even have...
Okay.
Anyway.
So...
Oh.
What was I going to say?
Anyway.
I'm going to make a hashtag right now.
And we're going to fucking decide this.
I'm going to make a hashtag.
Okay.
Uh...
The hashtag...
And you guys are going to help me.
Hashtag...
Uh...
Do you never plan to have...
Yes.
God.
Oh, I want people in my apartment.
Next scene.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait.
That's depressing!
Why do they...
Why do they have apartment?
Why?
Like...
I don't know.
Just...
I don't...
Where are we going to sit on the couches for?
Just hang out at my PC room, I guess?
I...
No?
I don't know.
No!
I've never had guests.
Even here, I've never had guests at my old apartment.
So like...
So like, what if family visits?
I'm going to get fucking bean bags.
I don't fucking know.
That's why I don't know what to get!
I don't want to get couches.
It's too much.
Couches are so expensive.
And also like...
Moving out with a couch is such a pain.
JL, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
No guests getting raised up.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Usually like, if I'm hanging out with people...
We don't go over to my place.
We just hang out...
Outside.
Like, I don't know.
It's just... why...
I usually just hang out outside.
Not like...
I've never... I have not visited...
Oh wait, no.
That's a lie.
Like...
You should just hang out outside or like...
With... at somebody else's place.
That have furniture.
That have couches, I guess.
Alright.
Um...
Furnish...
Furniture.
Okay, furniture.
Did I spell furniture right?
I don't know.
I'm too tired.
I don't know if I spelled furniture correct.
Oh thank god.
Okay.
I'm like so tired that I...
I don't know if I spelled furniture correctly.
Cass, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I haven't had guests for two years.
Yeah, I just visit other people that have couches.
Exactly.
I don't even have a couch at my...
At my old place right now.
Like, I literally...
I don't even have like...
Um...
Uh... furniture.
I mean I have furniture, but I don't have a couch.
That's the thing.
I don't even have a couch.
So...
So I don't need another...
I don't need a couch.
I don't think I ever needed a couch.
Like at best, having a couch is just a...
It's just like a...
A like extra bed for dad.
To sleep in.
So it's never been like...
Um...
It's never been like a thing.
Except for like maybe like four years ago.
I had a couch.
But like it was just not worth it.
It's just not...
It's just not worth it.
Alright.
Alright, let's see.
Um...
Alright.
Let me...
Let me pull it up.
Alright, so this is gonna be the...
I hope to god nobody has...
Let me check if anybody has used this.
Alright.
It'll be funny.
Okay, there we go.
What the fuck is this?
Bro, what the fuck?
What is...
How is it $6,799?
Oh, but it's free delivery.
Oh,
but it's free delivery.
Guys, don't worry.
It's free delivery though.
Basically, this is the first suggestion I see.
How is this...
Guys, but it's free delivery though.
And it's...
It better be for that price.
Like, what the fuck?
Guys, you're supposed to be helping me?
Guys?
I'm not...
Oh, thank god.
Guys, I'm not gonna need a table.
I just need like...
I literally...
Guys, please.
Guys.
Please.
Someone suggested corkboards.
But the thing is, I don't wanna use corkboards.
Cause I don't wanna damage my...
I don't wanna damage my letters.
That's the thing.
I don't wanna use it and like...
Pin my letters and like damage it.
Um, so I don't wanna use...
A corkboard.
I wanna...
Um, I wanna have something that will keep the letters...
Keep the fanmail...
Uh...
Keep the fanmail intact.
Um...
Alright, what else?
What else?
Cause I wanna be able to see it.
Oh, for the shrine?
Is this like a storage cabinet?
Oh god, that's huge.
Oh my god.
How much is this?
This item cannot be shipped to your...
Oh wait, it's cause...
Okay, display.
Guys, can you guys...
If you're gonna send me an Amazon link, can you guys like...
Make sure it's in Canada?
Oh, it's currently unavailable.
Okay, apparently not.
I can't.
Guys, also like...
Make sure it's available in...
In Canada.
Make sure...
Make sure it's available in Canada, guys.
Ooh!
Pokemon Kitchenware!
Oh, that's cute!
By the way, this stream is gonna be like an hour and a half.
Like, I'm putting my...
I'm putting my limit at an hour and a half.
Because I don't know how...
I don't know...
What I'm gonna be like in an hour and a half.
I don't...
I...
I don't know what's gonna happen to me in an hour and a half, guys.
Wait, what the fuck?
Do you guys put your butter in like...
What the fuck is this?
Ceramic?
What is that?
What the fuck is that?
Okay, wait.
What is this?
Why do you put your butter in ceramic?
I don't understand.
Is this like...
This is not an Asian thing.
This is...
Um...
Why do you need to put your butter?
Why do you need to put your butter in a ceramic dish?
I just make sure when...
When I have butter, all I...
It's convenient.
Yeah, but like...
This is what I do.
I get a Ziploc bag.
And...
I...
I get a Ziploc bag.
And I put it in the butter.
And then I put it in the Ziploc bag.
And then I put it in the fridge.
Alright.
What the...
Wait, is that weird?
That's how my parents did it.
Monkey see, monkey do.
What?
What's weird about it?
I get a Ziploc.
And then...
How am I barbarian?
Like...
What?
Wait.
You need Tupperware?
But that's how my parents did it.
And then like, I un-Ziploc bag it.
Can't spread cold butter?
You got weak fucking hands then.
What do you mean?
Yes you can!
Yes you fucking can spread cold butter!
You get the butter out.
My parents are Asian.
Am I?
Are my parents so weird?
I'm gonna check my fridge right now.
I know I don't have a butter tray.
That's for sure.
Alright.
Guys, it's even worse.
I didn't realize we've regressed.
My family and I have regressed.
Okay, this is what we do now.
This is what we do now.
So, you know how the butter isn't just like tin foil?
Or like the wrapping?
What we do...
I forgot this is what we used to do.
What we do now.
Because we've regressed a little.
Is that when we unwrap it.
And then we cut the butter.
And then we wrap it back.
And then we put it back in the fridge.
So...
It's no longer in the ziplock bag.
Okay, so that's normal.
That's normal!
Hey!
That's not bad.
Okay, I thought I was weird.
Okay, thank god.
That gives me hope that I'm not weird.
I'm not weird.
Okay, guys?
I used to.
How is that fine?
But a ziplock bag is not.
I don't understand.
How is that okay?
But like I can't put my fucking butter in a ziplock.
How is that weird?
It keeps it fresh!
Doesn't it?
Okay.
Am I seeing...
It keeps it fresh!
If you put stuff in a ziplock bag, it always keeps things fresh.
Isn't that why we have ziplock bags?
Yeah, but it's not like...
We do that too.
Like...
If it's in the fridge, it should be okay, right?
It's like why is...
We can put vegetables and like crackers in ziplock bags.
Why can't I put fucking butter?
Now you're definitely weird.
Affectionate.
I'm doing my best.
I'm doing my best right now.
Alright, let's look at...
Let's look at more jokey furnitures.
Okay.
Guys.
What is this?
Grow.
Guys, I need to buy...
I need to actually buy stuff.
I need it.
Guys, please.
I need to...
Guys, I need to actually purchase stuff.
Americans sending you American only items thinking the world revolves around them.
Shake my head.
For legal reasons, this is a joke.
Please donate.
Get out of the US.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Darkblade.
Okay, you know what's fucked up?
Okay, I was talking to some American dragoons during the meet and greet in Canada.
And then I was like, how does it feel...
How does it feel to be a millionaire in Canada with your American money?
And they were like, it feels great.
If I buy something for $1.50 it's basically free for us.
And I was like, that's fucked.
I was like, that is so fucked up.
Free of American money.
They were like, yeah.
It feels so nice to spend money in Canada.
Oh my god.
Anyway.
Arrivo has been...
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
The reason why Okay, I'll tell you guys the reason why.
So, the anime revolution it was really scuffed for our concert.
Because like, for a minute, it was so unfortunate.
But you know how she's traveling, right?
She's traveling at the moment, so she doesn't have her actual setup.
And because of that, we were trying to figure out the mixer situation.
We did tech rehearsals and everything, and it was fine.
But when we were doing the singing, she accidentally, she apparently pressed something on her mixer that caused the weird cutting in and out.
And we only found out until the concert was over.
And we were like, trying to figure it out.
We were literally like, we were trying to be like, I wanted her sound to be good for her next, because she had another concert in the UK.
So I was trying to help her figure it out.
And stuff.
Figure it out, and stuff, before her next concert.
So that's why!
That's why it was like, super, it was super weird.
But it was so unlucky!
It was literally one button.
It was one fucking button that caused all of that.
And it got, unfortunately, it was pressed during like, during, like, between the tech rehearsal and the concert.
Oh my god, it was actually...
But that means, Mint and I are planning a revenge concert now.
We are, we're planning on doing a revenge concert in the future!
Um, we're discussing it, but she's super fucking busy at the moment.
So I told her like, okay, like, um, let's plan this like, after after your, uh, your schedule lightens up.
Because it's like, super packed.
Including mine.
My schedule is like, super fucking packed too.
Like, we're both, we're both, WHAT THE FUCK IS THAT?!
What the fuck?
Sorry.
Sorry, I got...
What the fuck?
I got...
Like, this was in my tags.
What my... What?
Who wants to sit on this?
You didn't even link a website to buy it!
It's literally a picture!
I don't even... How... I don't even have a name for this.
Did you just literally Google crab chair?
Like, okay, this...
There's... There's not even a fucking link!
You just Googled... Oh my god.
You just gave me an image!
What am I gonna do with an image?!
What am I...
Like, what am I gonna do with a fucking picture?!
Alright.
Clearly, we're not gonna buy that.
Oh, wireless phone charger.
I have one though.
Yeah, I have one... Like, I have one on my desk by itself.
So, like, I don't really need that.
Just buy a lot of fucking long mower... I'm not gonna fucking buy... Oh my god!
I've always wanted to buy this!
Okay.
So, like, this is, like, something I, like, thought about for a while now.
This is, like, um...
Okay, I always thought it was, like, super funny, but apparently it's actually, like, really good for you.
Like, you can actually, like...
It's really good for sleep, but...
Um, I'm talking about these.
This.
This is basically a dog bed for humans.
So, like, it's on...
It was on Shark Tank, guys.
You know it's good when it's on Shark Tank.
So...
I heard that... I actually read it, but I actually saw videos of it, but you can actually, like, sleep for a very long time.
You sleep for a very... It's, like, incredibly comfortable, and... You know what?
I'm gonna order one.
I've always... Now that I have my own apartment that I rent...
Guys, it is $299.
What the fuck?
That is...
That is... Holy... Okay.
What is that in Canadian money, though?
Okay.
Alright.
Let's play a game called...
Guess which one's the American dollar version.
Let's play...
Let's... Guys, let's play a little game.
Guess which one is Canadian, and guess which one is American.
Okay.
That's so fucked.
That's actually so fucked.
What the fuck?
How?
Is this that bad?
Is there...
Please...
This is why my shop automatically accepts American dollars now.
Alright.
We're gonna play a little game, everybody.
I love playing...
Playing this little game that we're gonna play.
Alright.
So...
Hey.
Two hundred and ninety-nine dollars.
That's not so bad.
Oh.
.
Hey,
guys, but it's free delivery, though.
.
What?
Um... It's same...
It's delivered by the same company.
.
I don't understand.
I... I don't understand.
.
Do you not have a...
Do you not have a distributor in... Oh my god, there's a... Oh, thank god.
Guys.
There's a rip-off version in Canada.
Oh, thank god.
There's an off-brand version in Canada called KJY Zoom.
That I'm pretty sure is a lot cheaper.
Congratulations.
Oh my god.
Guys.
There's a rip-off brand.
I'm so happy.
And it's on Twitch Prime.
Sorry, not Twitch Prime.
And it's on Amazon Prime.
Guys.
Oh my god.
It's cheaper than the American dollar, everyone.
It's...
Oh my god.
It's even cheaper than the American version.
This is the best.
.
I can't believe it.
The Canadian off-brand version.
It has to be the same thing, right?
This bootleg has to be...
What does it look like?
It's literally the same picture.
Except they have like...
Okay.
The funniest shit is that you can tell that this picture is like photoshopped so hard.
Which is the dog isn't even actually there.
Which I thought was the funniest.
Okay.
So...
Cause like, the original picture from the actual... the real brand.
Um... from the real brand is... it's obvious that like, they're actually using it.
But like, this is the most photoshopped picture I've ever seen.
Oh...
I don't even think this dog is supposed to be there.
I know this dog is definitely photoshopped.
Like, look at this.
This dog is not there.
There's no way.
There's no way this dog is actually there.
There's not...
I don't even think this...
Wait, where's her feet?
Wait, you're right.
Where the fuck did her feet go?
Like, I don't even think this background is real too.
I don't even think this background is real.
But this is the photoshopped from the bootleg version.
Which I am a little bit tempted to get.
Okay.
Okay, I'll show you.
I'll show you.
I don't even think the baby is actually on... Guys.
Guys, I'm gonna show you this other picture.
And guys, I don't think the baby is even real.
I don't think that's a real baby.
I don't know.
Guys, I don't think...
I don't think that's a real baby.
I don't think the baby was on the bed.
I don't think it's real.
This looks very...
It looks off.
Where are the shadows?
Where are...
Where even...
Where is the shadow?
Where is the lighting coming from?
Like, here, here, here, here.
Guys, I don't think I should buy the app.
Guys, I don't know.
The more I look into it, the more I realize, maybe I shouldn't buy the off-brand version chat.
I...
I think that maybe the off-brand...
Okay, okay, this one's my...
Actually, out of all this image, I think this one's my favorite.
I'm gonna crop it, because I, like, I need you guys to see just how...
Like, how...
How off this is.
Okay.
Like...
Like, what the...
Why?
Why is there, like, a little line of...
I don't think the background's real, either.
This doesn't look right.
Like...
None of this looks right.
This doesn't...
There's something wrong.
Guys, but it's $200, though.
Guys, remember, it is $200.
It is $500 cheaper, everybody.
It's...
It's $500 cheaper.
Guys, I swear.
Alright.
Guys, I mean...
I mean...
It could be...
Okay, let's look at the reviews.
You're right, you're right.
Let me read the reviews.
Let's see.
I mean...
I like how somebody was like, It's okay.
The sides sag.
There's no support.
It feels like sleeping directly on the floor, because the foam is thin and flimsy.
I mean, there's some people that had good reviews.
Average.
The sides flops down and don't sit up like pictured.
Well designed to make it washable.
Five star dog bed.
Three star human.
However, the kids love it.
Hey!
I'm a kid at heart.
That's almost the same thing.
Right?
Okay, what are the reviews for...
Okay.
A lot of people really liked the...
Husband loves it.
A lot of people like the official one.
This is fucked.
Why is it $632?
This is so messed up.
This is so fucking...
Why is it $600?
Wait!
If you buy it from the official store?
It's more expensive?
The official... because like I was looking at a distributor.
I was looking at a distributor and the official...
The official?
The official store is even more expensive.
But I get free delivery though.
On Tuesday, August 13th if I order it within 9 hours.
Guys, I don't know.
Do I buy it?
Guys, do I...
Guys, I...
Guys, all I'm saying is that like, you know...
It's $696 Canadian dollars.
And like...
I mean...
It looks really comfy.
It looks really...
Just get the crap...
Okay, you guys were willing for me to buy the fucking Garfield table that was $6,700 but I can't have a dog bed that I can sleep in.
It's not for dad, it's for me.
It's not even for dad.
It's for me.
Garfield is worth it.
It's not even for dad.
It's worth it for me.
Okay, then I'm fine.
Thank you.
Okay, guys.
Just think about it, guys.
If I order it within...
I get the expensive dog bed for yourself.
Why did this person fucking put her dog bed on a bed?
Just sleep on the fucking bed.
Like, get a slush plushy bacon.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, okay, I don't...
This... I don't understand.
I don't understand.
Why would you put your dog bed on top of the fucking bed?
Just sleep on your fucking bed at this point.
Why?
Like, I thought that was supposed to go on the floor.
Like...
Isn't this supposed to go on the floor?
The other pictures are on the floor.
Why is this girl putting it on the bed?
Like, what the fuck is the point of getting yourself a human dog bed if you don't put it on the floor?
For the photo and lighting.
Dog bed for Doki.
Your human bed for dad.
That's a cool idea.
Thank you for the super chat, Kaz.
Thank you.
A bean bag bed?
That exists?
Bean...
Are we not gonna buy anything today?
Are we really, like, not making any progress at all?
Are we not gonna make any progress?
Oh my god, this reminds me of like, what was it called?
Arm...
Um...
Comfort pillow.
Do you guys remember that?
Uh... Oh my god, what was it?
There's like a pillow that simulates...
that simulates, like, a person, like, hugging you.
And I'm trying to remember what it was called.
So, like, you won't get lonely.
Is it called the comfort pillow?
It's been a long time.
Comfort... Is it the boyfriend pillow?
I remember that.
That, like, went viral.
Oh, there it is!
There it is!
This is what it looks like, guys.
This is what I'm talking about.
This has...
Okay.
Sora, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You have my first super.
This will buy you some ketchup.
This came out of any rebel budget.
Thank you for the super chat, Sora.
Thank you.
Thank you for your very first super chat.
Okay.
Alright.
When I show you this, the...
The punchline is the... is the description of this.
Okay, so this is called...
This is called the boyfriend cuddle pillow.
But...
The thing is...
What I love about it...
Is that...
It's a gag gift.
But...
What I... The funniest part about this gag gift...
Is...
The fact that...
You can get it for your mom.
If you wanna, you know...
Send it to your mom.
You know...
She would love that.
Oh my god.
There was like a legit one though.
I'm trying to remember...
Which one it was.
Oh, this one.
Is it this one?
There was like a legit like...
Happy Mother's Day!
Happy Mother's Day Mom!
I know you're lonely.
Thank you for the akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh!
For your first super chat too.
I appreciate it.
Hey Dokie, me and Sayaka had a great time organizing the banner for Annie Revel.
We were happy to meet other dragoons at the event.
Thank you for the akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
I am super excited to receive it.
I'm glad you had a great time.
Alright,
let's see.
Someone recommended me an air conditioner.
I'm not... what the f**k is this?
I am... what...
Okay.
Okay, guys.
Wait, Big Dave?
Oh wait, that's $975,000.
I didn't know that.
I thought that was $975.
Okay.
Guys, I need... I'm not gonna get a Minecraft lamp.
I'm not gonna get a f**king creeper... creeper alarm clock, chat.
I'm not gonna get... I'm not gonna get creeper alarm clock.
Guys.
Guys, I'm not gonna... Why am I gonna get $100 bills printed napkin tissues?
Okay.
Oh, is that... Okay, I don't like making coffee.
What the f**k is that?
Free crush proof plastic balls for a ball pit?
Guys, I know like mentally I act like a child, but guys.
Guys.
Please.
Please, I need...
Please, I need real friends.
Okay, guys, a chair.
Oh, what is this?
Bean bag chair.
Giant high-density foam-filling sofa with foot stools.
Oh!
It has a... Okay.
I mean, that looks nice.
Guys, the only good suggestions I had so far was literally the dog bed for adults.
Okay, guys, please.
Please...
Okay, I won't get a sofa, but this looks extra comfy.
Like, where would I sit?
Like, why would I ever sit in the living room?
Like, that's the thing.
I'm just like thinking like, why would I sit at the living room?
So...
That does look nice.
That looks dumb.
Hahaha
Chad is just like, that looks nice.
That looks like shit.
And it'd be super uncomfortable?
Alright, let's see what the reviews are.
I'll check the reviews.
It is one day.
This is not worth it.
It is misshapen and uncomfortable.
Very heavy and hard to return.
Okay.
That... oh... it's coming up, but the material is weird and not soft.
Not worth $300.
If it was like a hundred dollars, okay.
But headache in returning.
Guys, it's all in the title.
Poor quality.
Guys, I don't know if this is the right purchase.
Hahaha!
Wait, never.
It's misshapen and uncomfortable.
Very hard.
Oh my god.
Is there anything that's actually good?
Like, is there anything that's actually comfortable?
Oh my god.
Wait, what is this?
Wait, what the fuck is this?
This is $8,700?
It doesn't even have... it doesn't even have... it's not even on Prime!
Okay, I was suggested this.
If I make $8,700 right now on this stream, I will purchase this.
Hahaha!
If I... this is creepy.
What do it... what the fuck is even that?
No, you won't.
Yes, I will.
Hahaha!
Thank you for coming to Adiriva.
Love the concert and talk show.
I'm so glad you enjoyed it!
Kunari, I'm so happy.
You had a great time.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All I'm saying...
If this stream ends up getting $8,700 in Canadian, I will buy this chair at the end of the stream.
Hahaha!
Don't tempt... I will 100% do it.
This is what it looks like.
I mean, it's a terrible idea, but at least it's also kind of neat.
Guys, I don't think we're gonna make it there.
Hahaha!
That's not... how much is that?
This is what it is.
Okay.
Nox, thank you for this Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Yes, Doki, buy it.
Lord Kurosu, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Foolishness, Doki.
Foolishness.
All right, let's see.
Okay.
How much is that in...
Sorry, $8,706.
Because of shipping.
There's a $5 delivery fee.
All right.
What the hell is even that?
It's called...
The Scorpion Gaming Chair Floor Gaming Chair Ergonomic Computer Cockpit Chair with 16 Color RGB Light Zero Gravity Leather Boss Seat.
A high back chair gaming cockpit for office and home.
Green.
Don't forget, it is also green.
It looks dumb to it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for the...
Okay, but look at this, guys.
Guys, it's very...
Clearly, it's like... Okay, let me...
CAD to USD.
That is like...
That's like $6,000.
So, like, you know...
It's still pretty bad.
But, you know...
It's maybe not that bad.
All right.
Let me...
Let me talk about why this chair looks very comfortable.
All right.
It has...
It has an ergonomic health design, which I would say might be better than the Herman Miller.
It's scientifically designed to imitate human mechanics.
The cockpit structure fits the body curve and can support all parts of the body.
So, as you can see, this part, this scorpion tail would support the neck, the arm, and then the body would be the waist and the buttocks and then the thigh and the calf.
And then, like...
She's clearly gaming out of her fucking mind.
All I'm saying is that if we somehow raise enough money by the end of the stream, I will purchase this chair.
I don't think that even looks...
Are you trying to say that...
That Golden Helm V-MetalBR lied to me?
His profile is literally metal.
Are you telling me...
Are you telling me this guy...
This guy right here who made this beautiful suggestion to us lied to us?
That it is not healthy for me.
Um...
Thank you for the thank you, thank you.
Challenge accepted.
You get up!
What do you mean how do you get out of it?
You fucking get up!
Golden Helm V-MetalBR Are you in my chat?
Are you joking?
Or are you serious?
He definitely did lie.
I...
See?
I bought... This is my Kickstarter.
I am making a GoFundMe right now.
Hahaha You don't get up.
You just never leave.
Why would you leave?
It's... It's agronomic.
Guys...
It's literally... It's literally good for your back.
It's good for your... Um...
It's good for your neck.
It's good for your buttocks.
This lady literally said...
Look...
Neck, Arm, Waist, Butt, Thigh, Calf.
How?
What could go wrong?
What could fucking go wrong?
I'm doing my part.
Jonathan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I just need you guys to know a Herman Miller is cheaper than this chair.
I have a Herman Miller right now and I was a fool for buying it.
I was a fucking fool for buying a Herman Miller.
This chair is so good that this chair is so fucking good that there's zero reviews.
And that means that there's no negative reviews.
All I'm saying is that if there's zero reviews that means there's no negative reviews.
Alright.
Guys.
I found... Guys.
I found a...
You can buy it in America...
Oh wait, wait.
What the fuck?
What's the difference between...
There's an off-brand version.
How is there an off-brand version of this chair?
Why would anyone buy the off-brand version of this chair?
It already looks dangerous enough with the fucking monitors on your fucking face.
I don't trust the off-brand version.
There's an actual off-brand version of this.
And there's reviews for the off-brand version.
Why?
Don't buy the off-brand.
You guys, there's an off-brand version.
And the reviews are like...
Okay.
Alright.
This is...
This is the...
This is the reviews.
I'll show you guys the reviews for this.
Okay.
Alright.
This one.
And then...
Alright.
Let's see.
Here are the...
Here are the official reviews for this.
Alright.
For this amazing chair.
That we're...
If we crowdfunded, I will buy.
So...
This guy said...
It looks like a banana.
I'm not... I don't like bananas.
And then...
This other guy...
Was...
Was like...
Let me grab it.
Oh my god.
I need to reset this.
Alright.
Transform.
Reset.
Alright.
This is a banana scorpion, guys.
Ha ha ha ha.
So like...
The negative reviews...
It's not because it's a bad chair.
Ha ha ha.
It's just because...
They didn't like that the chair reminded them...
Of bananas.
I...
It's literally the same chair.
The off-bat chair is literally the same chair.
It's the same woman sitting on this chair.
They literally grabbed the photo from the official one and then like photoshopped it and gave her a background.
Like what?
Is this the actual background?
I don't understand.
I don't... did they... which one's the real one?
Which one's the real photo?
I assume this is the real photo.
But like this is from the off-brand photo.
Okay, I'm so confused, guys.
Guys, I don't know which one's real and which one's not.
Okay, alright.
I'll tell you why.
I'm really confused.
Okay, so... so you know how like... alright.
So, we saw this photo.
We saw...
We saw this photo.
Oh.
This photo, right?
But then... what the fuck is this?
This is from the off-brand.
Which one's the real one?
They're both the same lady.
But the logo is scrubbed off.
This one is the official one.
But this one's the off-brand.
Why does the off-brand have the official photo?
Why is there no logo on the desk mat?
There's a logo here.
There's a...
Which one's real?
I can't tell.
I... I can't tell.
Does that mean the off-brand was the real la la la?
The real and the off-brand has LED so it's better.
They all have LED so it's better.
What are you talking about?
Holy shit, the plot twist.
I don't know, because it's cheaper.
Which one's the real chair?
Wait.
But which one's the real one?
Which...
Which one?
Wait, I can buy it on AliExpress.
But it's also $6,800.
Okay, I'm gonna...
What the fuck?
Guys, it's on AliExpress, but for some reason, it's like the exact same price as Amazon.
So I don't think it's worth it.
I don't think it's worth it, guys.
Who created this?
A small price to pay for a peek.
Who the fuck?
Wait, but they also have the lady!
Wait!
The lady exists!
It exists in the AliExpress photo too!
But like...
It's a different background!
Which one's the right...
Which one's the real lady?
Who's the real lady and who's the fake?
Guys!
She's in a different...
She's in a new house!
Guys!
She's in the house now!
Hey, can I copy your homework?
Sure, but change something so it doesn't look like you copied.
Peter, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Tacos, thank you for the super chat.
Hey Toki, it was my birthday yesterday.
I wasn't sure what to get myself.
But then I remembered when I got into your body cam stream.
So I got some red dot optics.
Good luck for finishing your new place!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday.
I'll do you a belated birthday song.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Tacos.
Yeah!
Guys.
I think this is the real one.
But this is the off-brand.
This is the AliExpress.
And then this one is from the official website.
Not the official website, but the $8000 one.
What?
This is what cheap online stuff tells me.
They are both made in the same factory.
But they just changed the brand.
So do I get the off-brand stuff?
Is it made with cheaper materials?
Oh, guys.
It's not cheaper.
The delivery is $901.
They almost got me.
Yes.
The $8000 one was only $5 delivery.
I didn't see the $900.
Whoa.
They almost fooled me.
Why is it so expensive?
Because look at it.
I can't wait to get crushed by my monitor.
It's the dream.
Like who wouldn't want this?
Want all of this?
To be fair, I want the green one.
Actually, no.
What colors does it come in?
Okay.
It comes in black.
The black one.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Wait.
What does the red one look like?
What the fuck does the red one look like?
I feel like the black one looks the coolest out of all of them.
I'm not gonna lie.
The black one actually...
Oh, I can't tell.
The yellow one just looks like...
The yellow one does look like a banana.
It does look like a banana.
God, that looks so uncomfortable.
What do you mean?
It could be yours for $8700.
It's so...
What a steal.
What a fucking steal, chat.
Do they have it on eBay?
Maybe I can get it cheaper on eBay.
What if they have it on Keegee?
Would it be funny if it was on Keegee?
For those who don't know what Keegee is, it's basically the Canadian, like...
What's the word?
It's the Canadian...
What's that American version called again?
The one that got shut down because people were using it for...
It was, like, really bad because people were using it for...
For, like, anonymous hookups.
And then they shut it down.
The Craigslist!
Yes!
Anything but Keegee.
It's the Canadian Craigslist.
But there's no hookups.
There's no hookups.
You guys might not remember, but it sort of got low-key, like, shut down because people were using it for hookups.
It's still alive and what?
People still use Craigslist?
Holy shit!
Oh my god, they do!
It still exists!
Oh my god!
Just nobody uses that anymore.
Do they have the scorpion?
Scorpion chair on Craigslist?
Oh...
Wait, I wanna look at Craigslist now.
But what do they have in Craigslist then?
What do they have?
Oh my god, musicians?
Alright, guys.
What do we wanna learn?
Local news.
What's the local news for?
Oh, it's for, like, people, like, doing yard sales and stuff.
No Toki Craigslist.
It's...
Toki...
No...
Guys!
Maybe the...
Maybe the fucking...
Maybe they'll have the scorpion chair on Craigslist!
You can buy musicians.
You can, like...
There's child...
Guys, I don't know about you, but, like, I don't think, like...
I don't think, like, I would hire anybody for childcare on Craigslist.
I'm sorry.
But, like...
I don't know.
I feel like childcare is, like...
Would not be for Craigslist.
Just feels...
Just feels a little sketchy.
Yeah.
There's, like, so many other better apps and websites for childcare that, like, I...
No one should ever hire a nanny on there.
Like, I'm sorry for anyone that puts childcare...
Childcare listings on that website.
Alright.
Linus Tech Tips just did a garage sale and he sold his...
What the fuck?
Where does he live?
But don't dox him.
But...
Is this information public?
Like...
Wait!
I can buy the frog chair!
Oh, you liar.
You just sent me a picture.
Frog...
Froggy chair.
Buy.
Nox, thank you for the akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
I hope you're doing well and moving and all.
Thank you.
Me too.
I hope, like, I'll survive.
Get ready.
Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, my God.
I'm so sad.
I'm so fucking sad.
You can't actually buy the frog chair.
You fucking lied to me.
Wait, I can.
It's in Denmark.
Oh, it got sold.
God damn it.
Wait, I can.
But it's 3D print.
It's so tiny.
What am I fucking...
What am I gonna do with it?
Guys...
Guys, I can buy the frog...
I can buy the frog chair.
Guys, for only $15.
I can have the frog chair.
What's the catch, you might ask?
Well...
This is the catch.
For $15.
This could be mine.
No, we're on the Etsy territory now.
Oh, my God.
But what if...
Guys...
Oh, no.
We're on the Etsy territory.
It's fucking over.
Okay, guys.
Guys, it's like $99.
Do I do this?
A $99 American dollars chat.
This is $99 American dollars and I need your opinion.
I need your opinion chat.
Do I buy this rug?
No, I'm fine.
Guys, it's $99.
Guys...
I need a rug.
No one's gonna...
I won't have guests.
But...
Buy the...
Frog chair.
Toki.
Now.
Broken pot.
Thank you for this super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, it's only $99.
Guys, there's only 10 left.
Oh my god, 150 centimeters is like $900.
Guys, how big is 150 centimeters?
Guys, guys, I just didn't know how big is... guys, how big is 150 centimeters for the low, low price of $997?
Is that a lot?
Should I get that for my living room?
A giant club penguin?
A giant club penguin, right?
For 150 centimeters?
And then do I put it in my living room?
And then...
It would be really... am I really gonna do this?
Guys...
Don't... it looks like an old map.
Oh my god, it's okay!
We can get it.
We can get it in yellow.
Chat, dragoons, if the pink does not suit you, that's okay.
Because it comes in yellow.
Now we're talking.
It's in yellow?
My mind is now changed.
Yellow, let's go.
What's wrong with...
What the fuck?
Oh my god!
I'm scared.
Okay, I'm gonna... Okay, I don't wanna get like... I don't wanna get in trouble for showing this.
So give me a sec.
Let me censor this.
I don't wanna get in trouble.
I don't know what this is called.
God!
Oh my god!
This is God!
Goodbye, scorpion chair, because I don't think we're gonna make our goal.
I don't like it.
This is God!
They
have this and Cloud Penguin!
Why is that a thing?
How many cells do they have?
Okay, thank God.
Like, their cells are mostly the Cloud Penguin.
Right.
Oh my god!
How is this real?
I'm star rating.
It's good.
Okay, guys, I don't... I don't know again.
No!
My recommended is so bad!
It's so bad!
Oh no!
You guys wanna know how bad it is?
Now they're showing me sexy rugs.
Since I looked at the Nadia Pooh rug.
Now...
No, I can't.
I literally would actually get banned off of YouTube if I show this to you guys right now.
For the Cloud Penguin rug, buddy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I...
I actually... I actually think I would get banned.
Honestly, I would get banned if I show this to you guys right now.
Guys, we will buy one thing.
Out of this entire stream, we will fucking purchase one...
We will have a universal agreement.
To be able to buy one item in the end.
That's like... I'm not aiming for much.
I just want one item.
I just get the Club Penguin.
I just...
Please.
We have to agree on one item.
I just need one in the end.
That's all I want.
The Club...
Okay, either the dog bed or the Club Penguin rug.
Which...
Which one?
Oh my god.
Okay, but I already have a bed.
No, I can't do this.
I already have a bed.
I can't do this to myself.
Alright.
Guys.
Okay, I'm gonna let you guys pick.
Alright.
Club...
We're gonna...
Club Penguin rug.
Or...
Versus...
Dog...
Human...
Bed...
Club...
Penguin...
Rug...
Dog...
Human...
Bed...
And you know what?
We'll add bonus.
Frog...
Frog chair for ants.
For my...
For rats.
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
This is it.
This is...
We're gonna get one item.
In the end, we will get one item.
In the end.
The Club...
Okay.
I think the Club Penguin rug.
Alright.
But what size do we get?
Guys.
What size do we get for the Club Penguin rug?
Like...
This is like the most important thing we need to figure out.
What the fuck is the size gonna be?
Okay.
There's multiple sizes.
You can't be like that big anymore.
This is the biggest one when there's literally like fucking 700 sizes for this.
What color?
Yellow?
Are you gonna go with yellow?
Is yellow like what we're sticking with guys?
All right, it goes from 50 to 150.
Are we doing this?
Are we really getting 150 centimeters?
Is this- is this really my legacy right now?
Is this- guys, it is 997 dollars.
U.S.
by the way.
We're not fucking around with Canadian paper money today.
We are talking about the real money.
We're talking about- we're talking about real money.
We literally don't have any money.
We're talking about the Next God.
So even though we think it's okay wait.
Don't f**k with me.
Um away from you guys.
Uh there's a' cents that I want to make into my beau tar pets guide.
And I've got in that one.
God, it's an encore theme.
Okay.
This is $900.
This is $600.
This is $1000 including shipping.
This is $600 with free shipping.
I'm donating more to help you out.
Somebody was like, I voted for the frog chair.
No, I said $997.
$99?
Guys, the $99 option is 50 centimeters.
Are we gonna half-ass it at 50 centimeters, chat?
Is this what you guys want?
50 centimeters?
Is this what you want?
50 centimeters is...
You guys want 50 centimeters?
Okay,
100.
Are we compromising?
Do we want 100 centimeters?
100 centimeters is $339 American dollars, chat.
Is this what we're going with?
Alright.
We're gonna have one more pull.
Size...
This is gonna be my one purchase.
This is gonna be my only purchase today.
Like...
Size of the rug.
Dog bed, please.
50, 100, 150.
For my apartment.
My new apartment.
It's a dog bed!
100!
I didn't have 100 for...
There was like at one point...
Holy shit.
Biggest.
Can you...
I'm not gonna buy both.
They're both not worth it.
They're...
I hope they're not...
Both not worth it.
None get the bed.
Delay this.
You're tired.
This is...
We're at the point in life where like...
I am willing to buy...
The most...
The most fucking stupidest thing.
Go big or go home.
You did this to yourself.
Doggy, please.
No.
The penguin will not bring a joy.
Jeff Bezos doesn't win...
Because this is actually on Etsy.
The amount of money for this.
1K penguin rug.
I can't believe...
You...
Guys.
All I'm saying is that you wanted me to spend $8,000 on a fucking scorpion chair.
And now you're telling me the club penguin rug is not worth it?
Pinky fucking lane.
God.
But that was funny.
See if you can find it.
The scorpion is functional.
And worth it.
The scorpion chair is cool.
But it's...
But it's a scorpion.
Guys.
You guys were willing for me to spend $8,000 for this.
This was a business expense.
Oh my god.
Am I really?
Guys.
At least I didn't...
At least I didn't do what, like, Ludwig did.
And, like, Michael Reeves did.
Where they give you guys access to the credit card.
And then, like, you guys just bought whatever the fuck you want.
Thank fucking god.
Okay.
That's...
Doki.
Oh, okay.
Okay, okay, Doki.
Pick a rug.
That is perfect for your space.
Nox, thank you for the akasupa.
Thank you.
Guys.
Unfortunately, the Kickstarter slash crowdfund was, uh, not a success.
Yes.
I don't know if you guys ever saw.
But Ludwig, um, gave their credit card, uh, to the chat.
Or, like, they made chat.
They...
They let chat buy any item they want.
And, like, at least, like, I did not give you guys free will.
And then...
Thing is...
One of the purchases that they made on Ludwig's card was a fucking life-size Jackie Chan wax figure.
And, like, at least that wasn't me.
At least I...
.
At least I did not buy a life-size Jackie Chan wax figure and put it in my room.
Okay.
But Michael made a sick video from it.
Or...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm not giving you guys my credit card information.
Chat.
I'm not.
You guys keep...
I...
.
If I did, somebody would have used it.
I...
.
I would have used it to buy a fucking scorpion chair.
And it wouldn't be the only purchase that was made on the card.
.
You coward.
Why not?
.
You know you will.
Let's buy...
.
Yes.
If we crowdfunded it, I would buy it.
.
If we...
If we crowdfunded eight...
.
...
six K American, I would have bought it.
Just for the fact that, like, you guys already gave me the money for it.
.
But, like, we didn't make it, guys.
We...
.
We didn't.
We didn't make it.
So we have to pick between the penguin rug, or...
.
Or...
The dog-human bed.
The lack of trust between us hurts a lot.
.
All right.
Lay, would you or would you not buy the scorpion chair and if I gave you the credit card information, would you or would you not?
I'm waiting.
Alright, I've already lost track of Lay.
I'm so tired.
I've lost track.
Did they even give an answer?
I can't even tell.
I can't even tell if they gave an answer.
Are they saying yes or no?
Or were they a coward and they ran away?
Fucking coward.
You know I was right.
That's why you ran away.
You didn't want to lie to me.
You didn't even have the gall to give me an answer.
Yes!
They said yes?
NDA, sorry.
Thank you for the super chat.
Alright, we're buying the club penguin rug.
We've done it.
This is our...
Alright, 150 centimeters.
Alright, that is a giant ass rug.
I'm going to put this in my living room.
That's literally going to be the only furniture we have.
Wait, what?
Okay, I'm scared.
I'm actually fucking scared.
What do you mean by check my donations?
I'm...
What do you mean?
Next scene.
Okay, alright.
Let's see.
Oh no.
Okay, we didn't make it.
Next scene, thank you for the...
Thank you for the $500 donation.
Buy the human-sized dog bed, too.
Thank you.
Oh my God.
Thank you so much for the $500.
Okay, you scared me there.
I thought somebody actually donated $6,000.
And like, it's going to make me buy the scorpion chair.
Like, that bit, I thought somebody was actually going to actually do it.
Thank fucking God.
I was going to be like...
I made it so that...
Oh, it's the end of the stream because I was hoping that we would never make it.
So like, thank fucking God.
I don't even know where to put the scorpion chair.
That's the thing.
Like, where the fuck...
I'm not going to put my monitor.
I'm not going to actually gain from it.
I don't want to die from being crushed by the monitors of my scorpion chair.
So...
But I don't actually want you to suffer that much.
Next scene, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
In my scorpion...
Sorry, my banana scorpion.
Um...
But I will buy both the 150 centimeters Club Penguin rug and also the dog human dog bed.
And I'll take a picture of both and the same.
I'll put the dog human dog bed...
Actually, no.
Because then you won't see the Club Penguin.
I'll put it next to the Club Penguin.
So you'll see how fucking big the Club Penguin rug is.
Alright.
I'll make my purchase, like, after this stream.
And then I'll take a picture of it.
I love you.
Go buy whatever you need.
Nox, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You know what?
That was very productive, chat.
Buy the frog chair.
Okay.
I'll buy the frog chair too.
Cass, thank you for the magenta sofa.
Thank you.
I will buy the Club Penguin...
We were very productive today, chat.
Not only...
Not only did we buy some furniture.
We bought...
We bought three pieces of furniture together to decorate...
To decorate our apartment together.
The voting meant nothing.
Wow.
This is also a lesson to everybody.
That in the end, your vote doesn't...
Okay.
That's a bad lesson.
That...
It was an illusion of choice.
Choices don't win.
Choices matter.
Anyway.
I'm fucking tired.
So I'm going to call it here.
I hope you guys had a lot of fun today.
Hanging out with me.
And fucking around.
And buying furniture for us.
Buying furniture and everything.
I really did enjoy it so much.
Just hanging around.
And messing about.
And...
And actually purchasing some stuff for...
Definitely buying some stuff to furnish the empty apartment.
And it was a lot of fun.
It was a lot of fun.
I'm going to call it here.
No stream tomorrow.
Because it's Sunday.
And no stream on Monday.
Because I'm fucking...
I'm fucking tired.
I need the rest.
Anyway.
I'm going to call it here, everybody.
As always, everyone.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
To get that blood flowing.
Bye.
And if you stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.